[Musik]
in berlin bin ich jetzt verbunden zum
phönix tages gespräch mit katrin göring
eckardt fraktionsvorsitzende der grünen
im deutschen bundestag ich grüße sie in
die hauptstadt vor gering eckert ich
musste sie auch schon gemeckert aber es
ist sozusagen sehr sehr ernst wir haben
die zahlen gerade erwähnt und wir hatten
den beitrag gerade auch mit den
intensivmedizinern vor diesem
hintergrund muss es nicht wirklich sehr
schnell gehen trotz aller bedenken die
es vielleicht im detail gibt ja in der
tat ist muss sehr sehr schnell gehen das
ist die aufgabe vor der wir jetzt alle
gemeinsam stehen und wir haben schon vor
ostern gesagt wir sind jederzeit bereit
auch in den osterferien nach berlin zu
reisen mit einer sondersitzung darüber
zu beraten und ich kann nur alle auch
fördern jetzt bei den verfahren was vor
uns liegt schnelligkeit und
gründlichkeit miteinander zu verbinden
weiß es ja in der tat so dass jeder tag
zählt was wir jetzt hier vorgelegt
bekommen haben ist im übrigen nichts
anderes als ein notbehelf das ist noch
keine bundeseinheitliche strategie das
ist noch kein gemeinsamer stufenplans
auch noch keine wirkliche perspektive
für die menschen in unserem land aber
dieser not diese notbremse wenn die
nachgebessert wird kann es kalt im
moment mehr also kann und soll der
wellenbrecher sein und ein
befreiungsschlag schauen wir uns
sozusagen die beiden punkte die sie
angesprochen haben anna die inhalte und
b sozusagen das verfahren beginnen wir
also bei den inhalten am samstag ist
dieser gesetzentwurf durch das
kanzleramt in die runde gegeben worden
aber die fraktion gegeben worden
dann haben sie in einem interview gesagt
er ist dringend nachbesserung bedürftig
mittlerweile ist ja weiter im
hintergrund daran gearbeitet worden also
infektionsschutzgesetz 2.0 der
gesetzentwurf wie wie gut ist er oder
wie ist da irgendwie besser geworden aus
ihrer perspektive
ja er liebt uns ja noch nicht vor das
bundeskabinett heute morgen beschließen
und dann kann man das abschließend
beurteilen was ich wirklich wichtig
finde ist dass sich bei der arbeitswelt
ernsthaft etwas tut und die verordnungen
die wir aktuell kennen bedeuten noch
nicht das zweimal in der woche getestet
wird sie bedeuten auch noch
eine radikal pflicht zum home office ich
glaube da sind wir immer noch viel zu
lang wenn man sich anschaut wie viele
menschen nach wie vor in die büros gehen
gehen müssen und deswegen sagen wir das
sollte im gesetz verankert sein und dann
kann man daraus eine verordnung machen
und wenn man sich das insgesamt anschaut
dann muss man auch sagen es gibt auch
nach wie vor so regelungen wir haben mit
dem wirklichen leben nichts zu tun also
man darf eine person außerhalb des
eigenen haushaltes treffen übrigens
jeden tag auch eine andere
aber man darf für haushalte sich
gemeinsam treffen um zum beispiel kinder
zu betreuen gerade dann wenn und das ist
ein anderer punkt der noch nicht im
gesetz steht wenn die schulen
tatsächlich wieder wenigstens in den
wechsel unterricht oder in den distanz
unterricht gehen müssen und nicht erst
bei 200 wissen das können wir uns nicht
leisten bei der britischen variante die
sich ihre kinder überträgt ja also nur
noch mal um das klarzustellen sie haben
jetzt nicht in abrede gestellt dass sie
den vorentwurf bekommen haben vom
wochenende sondern sie haben gesagt sie
haben nicht das abschließende vom
bundeskabinett heute dienstagvormittag
beschlossene gesetz noch nicht vorliegen
aber das haben wir alle nicht insofern
ist also sozusagen ein liszt letztes
überraschungsmoment drin und natürlich
laufen auch die verhandlung bis zu
dieser minute
sie haben schon angedeutet wo man nach
schärfen muss beginnen wir gleich bei
diesen testen muss dass eine testpflicht
oder eine sozusagen test angebotspflicht
seien sie wissen der licht jetzt diene
auch drin liegt hier aus drin und
erstmal muss klar sein dass die
unternehmen zwei test in der woche zur
verfügung stellen müssen und das ist
eine dokumentation darüber gibt und das
ist für mich das entscheidende ob das am
ende gelingt oder ob das nur sowas ist
nach dem motto die tests liegen dann
halt da und dann hat man sie halt
hingelegt und ich glaube das ist
wirklich ein entscheidender faktor
viele unternehmen machen satz jahr viele
verantwortungsbewusste und indien machen
dass wir wissen aber dass es eben viele
andere auch nicht tun und genau da
müssen wir jetzt rein wenn ich mir
manches im baugewerbe anschauen wo ich
sehe dass die frage nicht wirklich er
abschließend betrachtet wird und ich
sage nochmal die büros müssen eben auch
zugemacht werden wo immer das irgendwo
geht und das gilt sowohl in der
öffentlichen verwaltung wie auch in der
genau das ist eine forderung der grünen
seit langem und auch von von den
gewerkschaften eine pflicht zum home
office aus zu sprechen das hat die
bundesregierung sich bisher nicht
getraut die große koalition mal schauen
so zu sagen wo wir dann jetzt wirklich
schwarz auf weiß landen
die schulen sind ein anderes großes
problem das alle sozusagen auch einen
wert geben inzidenz 100 und dann die
möglichkeit eben mit dem wechsel
unterricht und zwei tests pro woche ist
das etwas was sie zufriedenstellen kann
oder würden sie es dort auch anders
akzentuieren den schulen geht es jetzt
erst mal um eine inzidenz über 200 und
es ist keine klare vorgabe gemacht
worden was bei den schulen dann
passieren soll
jetzt gibt es natürlich viele schulen
die sehr verantwortungsbewusst mit ganz
vielen modellen unterwegs sind und ich
würde auch finde auch solche solche
modelle die dann sagen okay wir gehen
noch ins gemeindehaus und ins
feuerwehrhaus und machen da unterricht
wie soll es auch gerne geben aber was
wir nicht machen können ist in dieser
zeit kinder ganz regulär in die schule
schicken und sie am unter im unterricht
sitzen zu haben und dann am mittwoch zu
sagen wir machen jetzt mein test das ist
die realität im moment in deutschland
und deswegen sagen wir zum schutz der
kinder
und übrigens der eltern wir wissen ja
dass die variante sehr stadtkinder dann
auch an ihre eltern übertragen wird und
zum schutz der lehrerinnen und lehrer
die mitnichten heute alle schon geimpft
sind deswegen muss man jetzt dafür
sorgen dass nicht erst bei 200 sondern
bei 100 die grenze ist das wechsel unter
nicht selbstverständlich ist dass die
tests da sind an den schulen und dass
wir da wirklich für mehr sicherheit
sorgen
ich sage auch warum die bundesregierung
aus meiner sicht dass mich macht weil
sie eine sorge hat das gesetz damit
zustimmungspflichtig werden könnte ich
fände es bundestag und der bundesrat
beide beschließen würden weil dann hätte
man die einheitlichkeit von der wir so
lange leben man hätte man auch ein
klares bekenntnis beider
verfassungsgemäßer kann sind wir fast
schon beim verfahren aber noch einen
inhaltlichen punkt müssen wir machen
frau göring-eckardt beschränkung von
freiheitsrechten ist sozusagen mit
bestandteil der pandemie wir akzeptieren
das seit ungefähr 13 monaten
jetzt kommt noch mal dieses heikle wort
von den ausgangssperren ihre position
also ich vorhin schon gesagt ich finde
erst mal ganz zentral dass man sagt es
muss einen festen haushalt geben mit dem
man sich treffen kann
es muss zweitens einen unterschied geben
zwischen außen und innen wir haben ja
gerade aktuell eine diskussion über die
von den erosion forschern zurecht
angestoßen wir haben wenn ich es richtig
weiß ich bin nicht die expertin aber
draußen 20 mal geringere ansteckungsrate
als drin also nicht gar keine aber eben
eine viel geringer und deswegen außen
und innen unterschiede machen wir haben
vorgeschlagen beispielsweise dass sowas
wie die zoos die freiflächen in denen
freiwillige geöffnet bleiben können
damit man und wohin gehen kann
gerade auch mit mit den kindern und dass
man auf der anderen seite so was wie
sport im freien auch für kinder und
jugendliche unter 14 jahren weiterhin
anbieten kann so jetzt haben sie aber
nach den ausstellern befragten welche
durch nicht umgehen
wir haben im moment einen vorschlag den
wir nicht verfassungsgemäß halten alle
gerichte die bisher über ausgangssperren
geurteilt haben haben gesagt das kann
nur das allerletzte mittel sein das
allerletzte mittel wenn alles andere
nicht gewirkt hat und wer jetzt hier
minuten lang darüber gesprochen was
eigentlich für maßnahmen ergriffen
werden müssten damit sie wirksam sind
und das genau ist das problem was wir
sehen es ist verfassungsgemäß
wahrscheinlich nicht haltbar und
entweder man macht etwas was dann auch
durch die verfassungsjuristen bestätigt
wird aber dann muss man vorher eben alle
anderen maßnahmen auch getroffen haben
oder man lässt es zumal die wirksamkeit
der ausgangs starben ebenfalls sehr
umstritten ist die einen sagen das führt
dann dazu dass die straßen leer gefegt
sind die anderen sagen ja stimmt dann
gehen die leute nämlich schon um 19 uhr
los und übernachten dann woanders und
feiern die partie hat bis morgens das
kann natürlich auch nicht der sinn der
sache sein und deswegen bei den ausgangs
beschränkungen glaube ich dass kann nur
als letztes mittel sein aber dann muss
eben alles andere vorher gemacht
mutmaßlich werden wir in einem
bundesgesetz landen eine andere frage
können wir jetzt nicht mehr erklären
nämlich die frage wer früher einen
kanzlerkandidaten hat die grünen oder
die union sie auf jeden fall aber noch
ende april einen spitzenkandidaten ganz
herzlichen dank für ihre einschätzung
informationen phoenix tagesgespräch
katrin göring eckardt war dass die
fraktionsvorsitzende der bündnisgrünen
im deutschen bundestag merci danke